in this video I want to talk about two
different globular proteins and they are
myoglobin which is abbreviated MB and
hemoglobin you may have heard of these
two proteins before or at least heard
the names before and we're going to talk
about them and sort of there's
similarities or differences and you know
what's important to know about them and
how to understand what's going on with
them so we're going to first talk about
and focus on myoglobin so myoglobin
again abbreviated as MB the first thing
you might notice about myoglobin is that
this this mile portion if you recall
from before the not that I've mentioned
before just so may be of your own
knowledge that Myo means muscle you may
have heard of myofibers which are muscle
cells or myocardium which describes the
muscle of the heart things like that the
root Myo means muscle and this glob
portion here implies it as a globular
protein so um first and foremost is
myoglobin is a globular protein and
that's something we should keep in mind
and it's a globular protein that exists
in muscle cells and are its so it is
actually a water soluble protein ok so
what one thing that's very very
important to know about myoglobin after
I mentioned this specific thing here it
binds oxygen okay so it's ligand its
ligand is oxygen a ligand is just
something that combined something else
as far as you know the way we'll talk
about it here so o 2 or oxygen an oxygen
molecule can attach to two myoglobin so
now that leads me into this idea of the
function of myoglobin because this is
very very important to understand it's
very key to understand this the function
of myoglobin essentially is to bind and
release oxygen to the muscle cells bind
and release oxygen two muscle cells okay
that is its function and that is very
very important to keep in mind and
you'll see why in a moment okay so like
I mentioned o2 is the ligand now another
another bit that I think that you should
know is that its structure is simply one
polypeptide one polypeptide chain which
means um one type etc amorphous end
within this one polypeptide chain there
are actually eight alpha actually they
don't put it like there
this one polypeptide chain has eight
alpha helixes which we've mentioned in a
previous video so um specifically this
one polypeptide chain means that
myoglobin has the highest level of
protein structure that it has is
tertiary structure it does not have
quaternary structure right because it
only has one polypeptide chain okay
that's an important bit to keep in mind
so um this uh my book or my 11s has a
single heme group one heme group what is
a heme group so the same group is a a
prosthetic group oops
which essentially if I've mentioned
before it's a it's actually a tightly
bound a non amino acid non amino acid
component of a protein and there's
actually Oh what's it called a an iron
ion right um in this heme group okay
oh one more thing I wanted to mention is
that there are no beta confirmations in
myoglobin sorry I should have mentioned
that earlier anyway since it's a water
soluble protein right since it's a while
just water soluble protein the the
what's it called the polar side chains
are on the surface of the protein right
and the hydrophobic side chains are in
the interior of the protein one last
thing I want to mention about the
structure of myoglobin is that it has
two histidine residues right which if
you recall our polar side chains two
histidine residues in the interior of
the protein okay one of them one of them
anchors the heme group while the other
the other one is a helps bind the oxygen
okay and and also it also this one here
it also reduces the binding affinity of
some some toxic gases like carbon
monoxide so it loops reduces the binding
affinity of carbon monoxide right
probably run outside of the toxic gas
essentially the way it kills you is that
if you're bought if your muscles are not
getting oxygen right because they're
because the histidine is binding carbon
monoxide what ends up happening is that
if your muscles don't get any oxygen or
if your tissues don't get any oxygen for
instance like your diet
my twitch is a muscle you can stop
breathing and if you stop breathing
you'll die
anyway that wasn't very pleasant any
case specifically this history energy
that anchors the heme group is the
distal histidine and this here this one
here is the proximal histidine though
nitpicky details but that's sort of the
the idea behind myoglobin let's talk
about hemoglobin now so let's draw
hemoglobins chart over here
hemoglobin abbreviate is a CH B it's
also called maternal hemoglobin in it
and the hemoglobin that exists in adults
is called maternal hemoglobin in another
video we'll talk about fetal hemoglobin
and sort of what you know how that comes
into play with as far as globular
proteins go
so hemoglobin is also a globular protein
right and we can we can we know that
because it's hemoglobin right now if
you're again if you're familiar with
with maybe if you know knew that Myo
meant muscle maybe you know that he mo
right he mo means blood or is the root
for blood hemostasis hemophilia all if
you've heard those terms before they all
have to do with blood anyway so it's a
globular protein specifically a blood
protein and it is also water soluble it
exists in our blood right so it must in
our blood is very hydrophilic a lot a
lot of water a lot of it is water
and so this is also a water soluble
protein so so far they're pretty similar
in addition it's ligand is also oxygen
okay so so for these two proteins are
identical as the way we describe them
now let's get into the function and kind
of differentiate it to the function
again this is what separates the two a
great deal and I think is very very
important understand the function of
hemoglobin essentially is to take oxygen
from the lungs from the lungs to the
tissues right and the tissues includes
including muscles right okay so this is
very very important okay
now as far as its structure goes I'll
get I'll get back to the importance of
the functions and and when I in just a
moment actually the structure of
hemoglobin is a little bit different it
actually has four polypeptide chains
okay four polypeptide subunits of which
two of the subunits are alpha subunits
that are actually uh 141 amino acids
long and two beta subunits which are 146
amino acids long now they're very very
similar in structure in structure but
it's the the way it's denoted here is
alpha 2 beta 2 so those are the four
there's two so alpha units two beta
units this doesn't mean alpha helixes
and beta pleated sheets
keep that in mind these are just the
these sort of designations for those
each individual subunit um now each one
of those actually before I move on
before I move on to even more details
these four polypeptide subunits the fact
that has multiple sub set multiple
polypeptide subunits means that it has
the highest level of structures
quaternary structure right because it
has more than just one polypeptide chain
that makes up the overall structure of
the protein okay so that means it has
Kwan Airy structure okay
now with it with these four polypeptide
subunits can do is that since there are
4 pi peptide units each one can bind an
oxygen so this means that it can bind
four oxygen molecules each one of these
subunits right actually has an a heme
group oops not each subunits each
subunit has a heme group okay
so now um there are a few fun facts that
you should be familiar with as far as
hemoglobin goes okay so hemoglobins
little fun facts are it displays this
thing called cooperativity cooperativity
my spell this correctly cooperativity
honestly I can't spell um anyway it
displays cooperativity spelling is I
mean important I will agree but I just
want explain this to you anyway
this whole crew operative 'ti what is
what does this mean well what I'm trying
to get at here is that um the Y idea
behind cooperativity is that once this
the well it sort of goes back to this
idea that it has four subunits
cooperativity because this hemoglobin
can bind up to four molecules once one
subunit binds an oxygen the affinity for
oxygen at the other subunits increases
okay so let me mention that so once one
oxygen is bound at one subunit the
affinity for oxygen at the other
subunits increases it increases so what
that means in other word is say this is
that hemoglobin binds oxygen
cooperatively so to kind of give you a
visual of this imagine imagine
hemoglobin looking like this if we have
just as a very very rudimentary drawing
but imagine hemoglobin has this globular
protein and I'm splitting it up into
four subunits if we have an oxygen here
we have an oxygen here and it binds this
subunit right the affinity for oxygen at
these three locations will increase
these locations here these three other
three subunits will want to bond oxygen
more than they would have had there not
been this oxygen already
this subject so this this whole idea
here is is sort of based on a concept
called allosteric regulation right and
we'll talk about that more when we're
talking about enzymes but allosteric
regulation just to kind of mention the
sort of idea behind it is that the
binding of one ligand right or any
anything that combined a particular
protein the binding at one subunit has
an impact on the affinity at the other
subunits for that ligand
okay so associate actually that the term
allosteric means other site so so other
site or other location so um this
cooperativity is an important concept
about hemoglobin now now let's talk
about you know the two of them as far as
which one binds oxygen better right so
as some of you may already know the
answer to that question but I'm actually
going to just blurt it out now of these
two myoglobin has the higher affinity
for oxygen make it in purple has higher
affinity for oxygen right then
hemoglobin okay so why why is that okay
well if we think about it just in terms
of the definition imagine this you
breathe in oxygen right that oxygen
needs to go to your tissues let's just
say in this case we're talking about
your muscles right you breathe in oxygen
that oxygen goes to your lungs
hemoglobin binds the oxygen in your
lungs and takes it to your tissues in
this case your muscles once it gets
there it need to drop the oxygen off
what's it going to drop the oxygen off
to myoglobin well that means that
myoglobin has to have the higher
affinity for oxygen if it has to grab
the oxygen from the hemoglobin if
hemoglobin had a higher affinity for
oxygen than myoglobin did then
hemoglobin wouldn't give up the oxygen
to myoglobin okay so let's write that
write that down
so has higher affinity for oxygen
because
myoglobin needs to grab the oxygen from
hemoglobin it wouldn't be able to do
that if I had a lower affinity right so
because myoglobin want binds oxygen
better than hemoglobin it is able to
actually steal the oxygen from
hemoglobin okay so now let's draw this
sort of saturation curve as they call it
okay let's draw this out see what we got
here okay so now I'm going to do my best
to explain this curve so here on the on
the y axis we have this thing called
percent saturation percent saturation
and on the x axis we have the pressure
of oxygen and measured in TOR okay so
what we can imagine here is I'm going to
draw the actual the lines or the sort of
curves for myoglobin and hemoglobin
respectively or and sort of kind of
explain this as I go so let's just
hemoglobin or she'd me let's do
myoglobin first
myoglobin saturation curve looks like
this okay it is a hyperbolic sort of
graph that's this this little bend here
is kind of me being a terrible at
drawing but imagine this line is a
little bit more straight and this slope
is a little bit more you know just that
straight so this is myoglobin here okay
hemoglobin looks a little bit different
hemoglobin looks something like this
okay something like this okay so what am
I trying to get out here let me label
these axes or with with numbers here so
zero percent saturation let's just say
50% saturation is up here and you know
100 percent saturation is somewhere up
here okay the P po2 is the pressure of
oxygen so basically the higher the po2
means that the more oxygen oxygen there
is in the environment percent saturation
sir-sir describes how much of that
protein
is bound by that Liggett what percent
let me actually note that here this is
the percent of the protein bound by a
ligand a ligand in this case o - ok so
here if you at this point there's 50% of
myoglobin saturated or bound dog to here
50% of hemoglobin is is saturated so
what am I trying to get at here I'm
trying to say that if we have let's say
a you know a a po2 of one right one
that's a very low pressure whereas let's
say a pressure of like 25 is over here
okay now notice what we have here at 1
Torr we have this percentage right of
myoglobin bound whereas at 1 Torr we
have this much hemoglobin right or
something mild web excuse me so imagine
it like this myoglobin becomes more
saturated than hemoglobin at a given
pressure of oxygen right in order to get
myoglobin to be 25% saturated we only
need 1 1 Torr of oxygen whereas that all
that one tour only saturates myoglobin
maybe say I don't know maybe like 1 or
2% in order to get hemoglobin to get up
to 25% we need to add you know 25 tours
of of oxygen there needs to be more
oxygen in the environment to saturate
hemoglobin right but at 25 tour for
hemoglobin the the saturation levels is
near 100 okay so it doesn't take much to
get myoglobin fully saturated but it
takes a little bit more to get
hemoglobin saturated which sort of
implies that myoglobin because it's left
shifted has a higher affinity for oxygen
than hemoglobin does okay so let me know
at one thing that I mentioned earlier is
that this is a hyperbolic sort of curve
oops hyperbolic curve whereas this is a
sigmoidal curve for hemoglobin Sigma
Lytle just means S shape okay so this
sigmoidal curve is due due to the
cooperativity right of hemoglobin so
what that sort of is is how to explain
this is that at low concentrations of
oxygen we don't have a very high
affinity for oxygen here at least with
hemoglobin but as you as you add a
little bit more and more once an oxygen
is bound maybe the affinity shoots up
right so that's this is cooperativity
happening right here sort of in this
area here right once there's a high
enough once we know one oxygen is bound
the affinity for oxygen just shoots up
and then we have this upward curve
that's going you know what a crazy slope
okay so that is essentially it that I
wanted to mention about about these I
hope that video was helpful and I'll see
you next time when I talk about
hemoglobin and fetal hemoglobin another
different